da bist du herzlich willkommen hier
heute meine liebe zuschauer endlich zum
zweiten teil fahren letzte folge happy
so landete er auf der party von blair
und dem zusammentreffen mit ihrer
konkurrentin bzw dem schreck reilly und
genau da geht's jetzt weiter die
freundinnen von heidi loben uns auf
jeden fall für das kleid sie sagen dass
es sehr glamourös oben steht schon ja
dresses an die neue bi hot und wir
bedanken uns bei reilly und ihren leuten
wir bedanken uns dafür dass sie die
qualität bei gutheißen und ein bestens
beherrschen so entschuldbar die schützen
ok ok lehrer fragt sich natürlich was
sie damit meint und sie antwortet cut
the bomb the way you are a fashionable
labour party time to have a little john
little tinka unter euch die erste folge
happy sound mit luca noch nicht gesehen
haben guckt euch bitte zuerst die erste
folge epi somit luca an bord haben wir
eine art hangover plan ausgearbeitet mit
unserem beste jenna und in diesem plan
geht es darum wie will reilly von ihrem
thron stürzen wollen aber anscheinend
hat die diesen plan gefunden also mal
schauen was sich jetzt noch sagte
krebber an der as meldet reilly sagt die
blair party love and hate mailand spot
möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen um 19 auf der liste ist die
mice quad okay sagt die rallye und wir
antworten entweder adv und save you oder
what are you going to do oder das hat
mein ich würde sagen ich frage sie aber
was sie damit machen will you what you
won't stop till you get some interesting
apropos single release hot stuff lets
you bietet kis
lesen challenge was ist die kissel ist
challenge if you can't we can auf can
trust in lippels singles wie formel
alter das ist ja so eine richtige
challenges wenn wir das schaffen wird
reilly als head mit in crime
zurücktreten
jan schejbal parkings partner credit
basis ii hat in der schule ein privates
club black and white bull renault sagen
ihre freundin rief kentwood vor
[Applaus]
das heißt wahrscheinlich dass ich wieder
ordentlich doch in wuzhen abtes johan
riley aber kirste people on the list no
problem media motiven sleep richtige
alter ich glaube ich musste noch nie in
dem video so viele wörter zensieren ist
wohl way more fun taking over my new
wave szene
juli in linnich
das kommt natürlich auch sonst nicht
eigentlich auch lesbisch ist aber auch
egal dass jetzt auf jeden fall die
zweite seite der kissel ist die ganzen
leute sollen wir küssen
dieser level i can bus heart is not
going to be easy
you have no idea what i'm back office to
replace the oh ja das ist unfair
sie informiert jetzt die leute die auf
der kissel ist stehen von wegen du
darfst hier erklärt ich küsse josef
kollektiven juror schrieb ich weiß nicht
was im porsche preis also eins von 20
haben wir jetzt das bildfeld aus
entscheidendes tor i would like it quick
push notification wollen den user die
auf jeden fall egal wir sind wieder in
der cafeteria angekommen überall laufen
leute rum diary und squad gucken aber
und realisieren dass weder sitzen der
erste teil von youtube mc bizz liste new
value chains oder die bank of using this
new chessbase im alter.de jenna schaltet
sich jetzt ein er ist auch nicht wann
basic berti hier in die cdu auf endlich
springt so aber für mich okay und checkt
ab mit ihrer clique schießt
egal jetzt geht es aber so richtig los
freuen und zwar die gender fragte uns
okay you want to go after this list fest
also werden wir wohl als erste skizzen
der ja ich habe keine ahnung wo
headcoaches nicolae ich mach mal next
wäre es das hier das ist justin nämlich
niemand natürlich das mädel wir sind ja
homosexueller mehr gesagt er mit fusel
lola okay
die laura auf jeden fall schon gegensatz
zu den am besten schließt indes cool
schießt kitschige totally news sowie
mehr trubel getting hört händler
ich bin das größte kunstwerk der schule
hälfte werden als headcoach zu hause
müssen nur nach herankommen an die lola
ist ein up von artlas schießen ok was
die player alles macht alter muss die
mich eigentlich schon ehren wenn dieser
verdammten schule das leder geht auf
jeden fall zu chris hin und fragte
washing also wo sie hingeht
ach ja die spielt er fußball gespielt
kam supported ihm nie support-team only
have you score von ihm sage ich mal
die vier promis des kongo vom oldtimer
ist okay
die beiden sind auf jeden fall groß war
bronze bereits ab riga wir haben aber
eine aufgabe zu erledigen und zwar sind
wir auch schon hier direkt in der kunst
klasse angekommen war kommt sagt mister
grünbaum und sieht aus wie albert
einstein also wir malen heute früchte
raps und soja painting to the bone of
truth story ok to life also müssen jetzt
eine schale von früchten malen immer das
lola the day i can't even geld horten
notice mia wohl heftige lola station
artistik elia also wir müssen jetzt mal
wir wollen natürlich mit den händen ein
tolles bild
what do you think what ever so
du willst nicht verarschen lola haben
entweder sagen wir jetzt what's your
problem oder herz- oder yours amazing
ich glaube wenn sie sie ist damit sie
hören dass ihr super ist also just
amazing
die das sind komplett aus mainz tax tür
okay aber wir haben vor ihm sitzen im
bett mit ok
er küsst mich einfach dann ist alles gut
wir fragen natürlich warum sie eine
schlechte stimmung gerade hat beim
trinken snort jubilar der wird dann in
europa eric single class is that same
thing i just wanted to use the pains ach
ja klar also ich mein spray tans und das
komplett ich verstehe nur bahnhof
inspiration ist apfel käding what if i
could convince hingegen der
immobilienmesse schaue mich zum spray
knies after glas ich merke da geht
absolutely sagt die lola konvention beim
toilette spray paint and chill oder abo
privat lassen after class m kommt aber
kaum dicker was man nicht alles für
dieses projekt hier views classical
materials indes class classics who
safely betatest pablo picasso oft die
kasse of pain and with new materials
du hast kein stoff liegen bei yes we can
sagt minister grünbaum und mais missriet
okay sie darf jetzt also natürlich mit
den sachen machen wir springen ein
bisschen wir davor haben alle klatschen
und mal schauen was die lola jetzt sagt
ok 14 miss li impress take you we would
you so much picasso ist da die team ohne
lift in franz mein gott okay jetzt kommt
mir die übelsten lücken raus fragen
reicht das ja sooo geil alters bietet
news als been looking for plague of
things but never im used-look euch doch
einfach denke also wir haben jetzt hier
unsere private lassen mit der lola
sie sagt auf jeden fall dass wir das
schon ganz gut machen unsere hände
berühren sich und sie zeigt uns wie wir
richtig malen die beiden sind auf jeden
fall wir schon so ein bisschen amrum
flirten
mega geil mit der privaten lesson knew i
have to sing sing pineapple ok setzen
einfach eure unterschrift drunter misst
der grünen baum foot locker mit straight
power frau ja jetzt werden auch
kriminell hier irgendwann hat mister
cool baum mal gesagt 102 m ich glaube
das müsste passen etwa youtube youtube
blog des project wunderkammer wurden
müssen bis die youtube great but mine
red lake areal street artist of the date
steht hier ok wahnsinn
die beiden laufen jetzt aneinander
vorbei machen jetzt hier den schwachsinn
müssen jetzt natürlich erst mal noch das
ding da irgendwie unterschreiben noch
nicht wieder zurück und so weiter und so
fort
sie sind jetzt wieder in der schule da
stehen wir gerade little tipp von
econsense student ok walter reilly hat
uns einfach verpetzt bei dem lehrer das
geht ja überhaupt nicht klar
mal schauen wie es weitergeht wir müssen
nachsitzen ich wollte nie beeindrucken
reiser die brille dieses spiel raubt mir
alle nerven
an der stelle der heutigen episode
episode allerdings auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn ihr wissen wollt wie
es weitergeht mit blair und lola hier
beim nachsitzen oder allgemein unserem
kampf gegen reisen gibt dem video einen
hoch schaffen wir 50.000 like
das mega mega krass wird auf jeden fall
zeigen hey ya bock auf das projekt um
nächste woche soll nächster path kommen
abonniert zudem gern hier unter dem
video meinen canalis ist kostenlos und
verpasst keine videos mehr und schreibt
mir auch mal und in die kommentare
was sich in der nächsten folge machen
soll also soll ich wieder geld ausgeben
oder soll ich wieder so ein bisschen was
anderes mal antworten zur abwechslung
jedes entscheiden also scheinen die
kapitale
[Musik]